Mời có thể thích tâm của tập bản vì thúc phòng xe cộng đồng không phải chỉ dịch cảnh hạm
mà là hành trình kéo dài rất khách thích.
Chúng tôi cho gặn là ký rại cửa.
Nóng này với chủ đề khiến chỉ phòng xe nó gần nó phùa,
với tối với tâm, đăng bý tụi chức, tự kiệt.
Mà có những 2 mình nâm đậu phòng xe của tụi cửa đồng.
Chị tôi mỗi những chiếc hẹn với cộng đồng.
Để nhìn biệt một số người đã làm được,
trong số thay mới năm qua,
mà gọi đến đây là tụi chức nối với tụi chức khách.
Những cái cán trên tụi chức đang làm tự kiện
vì công đồng đều thay là hợp thách.
Chị sẽ đồng hành như nhau về bí tụi xe.
Tại sao công đồng này cảnh tôi ở dưới?
2 mình nâm, một quán đường chỉ có thể đi được bằng sự kinh trị
và lòng thịt vệ trinh thành.
Chồng mong mùa dài, hương hình áp rời,
không chỉ là nơi vinh xanh những mùi xa tạo vì công đồng.
Con thế, đây là đi vẻ của những con người dưới lừa
những người lặng lại phục sử bên vị theo đôi như tụi tế.
Giô rất phát triển của họ đưa khi chỉ lặng một dạy.
Lặm đưa gì đó, có hương trong hiang.
Tụi lặng ngoài mà ta không thằng trong hàng mới dưới ám.
Được đợi đứt.
Nhưng mình này sổ đi tụi đợi đợi.
Nhưng một dưới,
chúng ta có tính lặng quá là một đồng.